welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for a
presentation titled workflows for
glycosylation
and cyalic acid analysis of
biotherapeutic
glycoproteins it's my pleasure to
introduce you to
dr john yan applications chemist for the
bio consumables
portfolio within the chemistries and
supplies division of agilent cross lab
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them
in the q a box our speaker will address
your questions
following this presentation please join
me in welcoming
dr yan i will now turn the presentation
over to him
good morning and thanks for joining us
today for this lab roots virtual event
my name is john yan and i am an
applications chemist here at agilent
today i will be discussing workflows
work like constellation and stylic acid
analysis
of biotherapeutic glycoproteins
here is an outline of what we will be
covering today we will talk about the
importance of inland glycans in terms of
biotherapy
function as well as as structural
analysis during the development process
we will also discuss fluorescent dye
options that can be used for analyzing
analysis
specifically we will cover the benefits
of dyes that we offer such as instant pc
with its high fluorescence and ms
response properties
we will also discuss an improved
workflow that has been developed
for the well-established glycan dia2ab
we also talk about helic-based
separation options that agilent can
offer
that utilize both fluorescent and ms
detection options
and finally we will discuss stylic acid
quantitation and analysis workflows
we will go through a plate-based total
salic acid quantitation workflow
as well as how to profile different
stylic acid species
via an lc workflow with fluorescence and
ms detection options
approximately one-fifth of all proteins
currently in the swiss pro database are
known to be like oscillated
glycosylation can impact protein folding
stability and function
glycosylation imparts diversity based on
differences
in glycosis in sight icann composition
glycan length
and structure as it relates to
biotherapeutics
more than 60 of currently marketed
biotherapeutics are glycosylated
glycosylation can be a critical quality
attribute
and even when it is not is often still
monitored as a product quality attribute
monoclonal antibodies and antibody
derived therapeutics
are glycosylated as are other molecules
such as blood factors like epo
and more than 100 biotherapeutics have
been approved in the u.s and europe in
the last decade
making characterization of these
molecules very important
here is a summary of the top selling
pharmaceuticals in 2019
this list is this list is dominated by
biologics
with eight of the top ten molecules
being biotherapeutics
and all eight of these biologics are
also glycosylated
so we can see that there is definitely a
trend towards biologics
and that glycosylation is a
post-translational modification
or ptm that is very common making
glycosylation something that needs to be
analyzed
and characterized during the development
process
now that now that we know that many
biologics are glycosylated let's take a
look at the
structure structures of common and and
glycans found on biotherapeutics
glycans are made up of multiple
monosaccharide units such as glucose
mannose galactose and acetyl glucosamine
also known as buckneck and solid acids
the common glycans found in molecular
antibodies can be classified as complex
biantenary glycans
because of the presence of the two glock
neck residues attached to the glycan
core
shown here on the left hand side this
quad can
is commonly referred to as g0f or fa2
the presence of core fucos
shown here as the red triangle has also
been associated with reduced adcc
activity
when present on glycan's above
therapeutics making it a desirable
making it desirable to develop molecules
with less glucose
the structure to the right of the to the
right is g2f
which is g0f with two galactose residues
lactose has been associated with
increased cdc activity
additionally the presence of termitic
acid linked to the galactose can lower
the rate of clearance
this is that is the presence of silica
acid can increase the amount of time
that the therapeutic stays within the
body on the right hand side of this
of this slide is the structure of g2 fs2
a
antenna and glycan with two silic acid
residues
something else that is worth pointing
out is that the linkage of the of the
of the silic acid molecules produced in
show cells predominantly generate
glycans
where the salic acid is linked in the
alpha-23 form
shown here on the bottom while above
that
is an example of alpha-26-length
cylination which is seen in human cells
later on we will we will talk about
these differences in a little bit more
detail
another category of van glidekins that
is closely monitored during the
development process
are high mass glycans shown here are
high mass glycans man 5
6 and 7 but these high mass glycans can
go up to 8 and 9 as well
these types of glycans are immature
glycans
that are often produced under strenuous
conditions
and suboptimal cell culturing processes
and
when the cells are being pressured to
produce at higher tidal levels
high minus glycans can increase the rate
of clearance
so it's something that is monitored
during the development process
on this side we have examples of
non-human type glycans
oftentimes biotherapies are expressed in
non-human expression systems
so non-human glycans should be monitored
due to possible immunogenic effects
humans don't have the ability to make
that gal alpha gal antigen shown here
which could be possibly be immunogenic
and finally the presence of non-human
stylic acid
so often called enigma or nu5gc
is also monitored due to potential
immunogenic effects
we will discuss this in a bit more
detail later towards the end of the
presentation
when we discuss how to monitor different
types of stylic acids
now that we have some background of what
type of what glycans are and why they
are important
how do we go about analyzing glycans
there are many different options
but cost solution can be looked at at
the intact protein level
here lc in combination with high
resolution accurate mass spectrometry
can be used on the intact protein or
sometimes on the subunits
to give information on the types of
glycans that are present next down we
have glycopeptides
here glycoproteins are digested with a
protease into peptides that can again be
separated by lc
and analyzed by tandem ms this along
with database searching is useful for
getting site-specific glycosylation
information next we have released and
glycans
here glycans are enzymatically released
with an enzyme such as p and jsf
and the released glycans can be can be
labeled with a fluorescent dye to enable
detection in combination with lc or
sometimes ce separation
glycans can be analyzed with without
labeling but this is much less common
than labeling the glycans
and finally glycans can also be
monitored at the monosaccharide level
here glycans are acid hydrolyzed into
their individual monosaccharides
afterwards the myosaccharides can't be
analyzed directly or after labeling with
a fluorescent tag
for this presentation we are going to
focus mainly on released
and derivatized and glycans here the
output is generally relative percent
areas
of the different glycan species we'll
also cover total silac acid quantitation
workflow towards the end of this
presentation as well
here's an overview of the offerings that
agile offers for released and glycan
workflows
there are automatable workflows for the
ascii map bravo liquid handler
utilizing the glycoprep sample prep
workflow with
with dyes instant pc instant a b
2 a b and a p t s we offer
a rapid sample prep option with our gly
x workflows with
instant pc 2a b and 2a b
we also have lc separation tools with
our 1260 byliner lc
and 1290 uh blc systems as well as
advanced bioglycan mapping
helicons and of course we have mass
spectrometers as well as other detection
tools
for the detection of released and
glycans
and we have software tools like
bioconfirm for the backend data analysis
part of the workflow
now i want to talk about end glycan
sample preparation and how it has
evolved over the years
traditionally and liking the sample prep
has been a very time consuming process
that could take one to two days with
overnight de-glycosylation and overnight
labeling steps
that are time consuming and labor
intensive
in 2012 prozam introduced glycoprep
an all-in-one solution workflow that
reduced the sample preparation time
down to four to five hours with
traditional reductive lamination dyes
such as 2ab and apts
after that glycoprep with instant a b a
rapid glycosamine
glycosylamine reactive dye was launched
this reduced
the prep time to three to four hours
and most recently prozyn launched yx the
gliac platform
that brought the prep time down to two
hours for reductive ammunition dies
and less than an hour of rinsed and dies
these two are these two top these two
workflows at the top of what we'll be
focused on
on today
here's the schematic of the gly x and
glycan sample prep platform showing how
it works
the input glycoprotein is first
denatured with a proprietary reagent
for three minutes at 90 degrees celsius
this open
opens up the protein for diego
costlation by pngsf
which takes place over the course of
five minutes at 50 degrees celsius
after this the glycans are then labeled
with your choice of 404
for instant dies such as instant pc
instant human instant ab
the dye labeling is rapid and is
complete in one minute
for traditional reductive ammunition
dies at 2ab and apts
the labeling process takes 60 minutes i
should point out that there is no dry
down step
prior to labeling which is often the
case with traditional reductive
ammunition dyes
after labeling the glycans are cleaned
up to remove excess dye
this process takes about 15 minutes and
now the labeled glycans are ready for
separation and analysis
this slide shows the efficiency of the
glycerostylation method
for a few different therapeutics looking
at the deglock oscillation
by bioanalyzer we see greater than 99
degree oscillation efficiency or targets
that we have looked at
including rituximab zatuxumab ambro
and zeldra the example shown here is the
toxomab
where the n glycan sites on both the fc
and fab region both on the heavy chain
separating the p and gsf versus node
pjsf control
output bioanalyzer the intact heavy
chain
in blue is shifted to a d glucoside peak
in red
this shows that the glyceration workflow
is efficient at releasing the
n-glycans linked on these molecules
next let's talk about the different
labels uh choices available for release
and glycan analysis
on the top half of the slide we have
glycosamine reactive instant dyes
such as instant pc with this high
fluorescence um
an ms response if instant q which is a
negative h charge die
for our glide qce system and instant ab
which is which was the first generation
instant dye developed
for lc separation with fluorescence
detection
we also have other workflows that
utilize reductive ammunition dyes such
as 2ab
and abts we do not offer a workflow
for 2aa but we do have many pre-labeled
2aa standards available for purchase
this is the structure of instant pc
shown here there's a tertiary amine that
helps
the label glycan ionize efficiently
efficiently and gives it the high ms
response
the procaine core of the dye gives it
the strong fluorescent signal
and there is nhs carbonate that is the
glycosamine reactive portion
that gives it the instant or rapid
labeling property
workflow time for the gliac sample
preparation with this die is around 45
minutes or 16 samples
and an entire 96 well plate can be
completed in about an hour and a half
on this slide we have a comparison of
different labeling dies
including instant pc and 2ab this is
from work prosim previously released
presented at an asms poster presentation
we can see the benefits of instant pc in
terms of both fluorescence and ms
response compared to 2a b
now that we understand how to get to a
labeled y-hand
what is the next step in the analysis
process
one of the most widely used methods for
separation analysis of
fluorescent-labeled glycant is liquid
chromatography
and the chemistry of choice is typically
hydrophilic interaction liquid
chromatography or helic
separate glycans can are detected with
fluorescence
and relative percentages of the
different glycan species can be
determined
ms detection is announced and analysis
is also an option
to aid in identification of different
glycan species
shown here is an example of a 60-minute
helic method
going from high organic to high aqueous
over the course of the gradient
to loot the labeled glycans this is just
an example and methods can be customized
to the user's need
azure alpha also offers different
columns that can be
used for analysis including a 1.8 micron
column suitable for uh plc types
operations
as well as a 2.7 micron column that is
compare compatible with lower pressure
hplc systems
here is an example of what instant pc
labeled glycans from a toxic map can
look like
we see mainly by entering neutral
glycans such as g g0f
g1f and g2f both levels of acceleration
these are the glycans g2 fs1 and g2fs2
and we see a small amount of man5 all of
which are consistent with the type of
glycans normally seen
on a monoclonal antibody
here is an example of instant pc labeled
glycans this time from the fc
fusion protein embrol or intercept
we see the same brian terry neutrals as
we saw before with rituximab
g0f g1f and g2f
but this sample also contains more more
examples of silent glycans
on the receptor portion of the molecule
these are g2 s1
g2 g2 fs1 g2 s2
and g2 fs2
here is the example of what the ms total
ion chromatogram looks like
for embryo and glycans labeled with
instant pc
we can see the ms response on the bottom
can almost be overlaid on top of the
fluorescence above
above it this high ms response property
of spc can aid in identifying
low abundant glycine species by mass
spec
here is is what the mass spectrum of
this npc labeled mann5
from the sample looks like we typically
see the m plus 2h form
as the major addit of bioentering
glycans for larger glycans it is also
possible to see m plus three
protons as well
when ms may not be an option for aiding
an identification
we also offer a wide selection of mica
standards
labeled with instant pc we offer quant
qualitative standards of instant pc
labeled vikings shown here to help
support those
by trying to transition to this die from
older traditional dyes
our selection includes individual
glycans such as
common bite antenna and glycans commonly
seen
on igg molecules produced in shell cells
we also offer different libraries of
instant pc the above glycans
such as human igg as well as out both
alpha 26
and alpha 2 3 siloated lycan libraries
please check out our website for full
details of the different glycan
standards that agilent offers
an added benefit to the use of standards
is being able to distinguish
between alpha two three and alpha two
six lancelic acids
it has been reported in the literature
that the that a2f
or g2fs2 which can have
stylic acids linked in either the alpha
2 3 or alpha 2 6 form
have different retention times based on
the two different types of linkage types
here's an example of instant pc label
standards analyzed under the same
conditions shown that shows the alpha 2
3 form on the bottom having a shorter
retention time
than the alpha 2 6 form on top this can
be quite helpful as even ms analysis
on its own would not be able to help
determine the differences in the xylic
acid linkage
on this slide we have a comparison of
our instant pc labeled triantenary style
libraries
alpha 2 6 version on top and the alpha 2
3 version on bottom
both analyze under the same conditions
we see g3 the tri interior structure
without silic acid
has has the same retention time in both
samples but with the addition of stylic
acid
up to three residues attached to the
terminal galactose
we see that the retention time is
shorter for the alpha 2 3 versus the
alpha 2 6
form on this slide
like the previous example we have a
comparison
of our ipc or instant pc silated
tetraenterium library
similar to before the g4 structure
without salic acids
have the same retention time but as
sonic acids are added
up to four on the four terminal
galactose residues
the alpha two sixth forms have longer
retell have longer relative retention
retentions compared to the alpha 2-3
forms
here is a summary of additional
application notes and technical notes
that are available on our website
or upon request that describe the use of
instant pc
feel free to download these resources
and reach out to us if there are any
questions we can help answer
now i want to shift and talk about our
gliacs with a 2ab workflow
2eb is a traditional die but now
available with the added benefit of the
gliax workflow
this can be a good option for those that
want the benefit of a rapid workflow
but want to be able to to relate new
data to historical data
since 2ab has been a well established
glycan labeling diaphragm in many
laboratories
over the years
like the glass with instant pc workflow
we have the same in solution
denaturation and declare constellation
steps
for this 2 a b workflow the difference
we have here is that the reductive
ammunition labeling step
is completed on the matrix of the 96
wall cleanup plate
this takes 16 minutes at 60 to 55
degrees celsius
this requires no dry down which is an
added benefit compared to traditional
methods
after labeling the glycans are again
cleaned up to remove excess dye
and are then ready for analysis total
preparation time is around two hours
versus older methods but that can be
much longer
here is an example of what two a b
labeled angle icons from a text map
looks like
similar to what we saw previously with
instant pc
we see mostly binary neutral glycans g0f
g1f and g2f and we see
good percent cb values for the major
glycan species
here is a dirt comparison of the glycam
profiles for 2eb on top
and instant pc on bottom both for
rituximab
we see the ma the same major glycan
species g0f
g1f and g2f but the relative retention
has shifted
under the same analytical conditions
since 2ab labeled glycans
earlier compared to instant pc labeled
glycans
and here is a side-by-side comparison of
embroil or antennaceptin
and glycans we see similar results for
the two dyes as well as some added
benefits in terms of resolution for
instant pc under these
lc conditions we see pairs of glycans
such as g1
fs1 and g2f can have better resolution
when labeled with this new pc compared
to 2ab
under these specific conditions
and here's an example of the total ion
chromatogram for 2ab labeled and glycans
from membrane
we can see that the total ion
chromatogram or tick or 2a b labeled
glycans doesn't compare to what we can
see within the pc
this is the one atom this is one of the
added benefits of instant pc
the ms signal makes it much easier to
ide like hands
by mass with confidence
here is a list of two a b label
standards that we offer
we have many of the common glycans seen
on biotherapeutics
as individual standards as well as 2ab
libraries such as human igg
and glycans and several different
satellite libraries
both alpha 23 and alpha 2 6 linked salic
acids
on this side is an example of our 2ab
asylum
trinitarian and glycan library analyzed
by lc with fld detection
on top we have the alpha 2 6 library and
on the bottom we have the alpha two
three version
similar to what we saw with instant pc
the alpha two three linked stylic acids
have a shorter retention time when
compared to the alpha two sixth form
we see g3 with no oxalic acids
have the same retention time but when
the salic acids are added
to the terminal galactose the alpha-26
form has a
has a longer retention time
before moving on and discussing our
silica acid analysis tools
i want to talk briefly about enzymes or
more specifically excellent causations
that can be used as an additional method
to confirm structures
of and glycans we put together this app
note in early 2019 using enzymes
validates
galactosidase and hexosaminase to digest
specific monosaccharides off the intact
glycoproteins
prior to releasing living within pc
is an example of how these enzymes can
be used to determine the structure of
glycan membrane starting at the top is
the control
without with no excellent glycospace
treatment
below that is a profile of solidus
treatment
we can see that the cylindrical glycans
have been knocked down
and we see an increase in the
glycosylated peaks
below that is the combination treatment
of solidaze and beta glyphosidase
this removes both the xylic acid and
galactose monosaccharides
and we see an increase in g0 g0f and
man5
glycans and finally when solid is
beta glantosidase and hexocemandase were
all used
at the same time we see a shift to only
mann3
man3f and man5 this can be very useful
method to determine glycan structures
when ms is not an option or is an
orthogonal method complement ms analysis
now i want to shift to the topic of
solid acids on bio therapeutics
and talk about some of the options we
have for total style gas quantization
as discussed earlier sonic acid serves a
critical role in mediating the
effectiveness
of therapeutic microproteins the
presence or absence of stomach acid at
the non-terminal
at the non-reducing terminal of
anaerobic glycans can impact the
particle kinetics as well as
immunogenicity
of the protein which is why maximizing
the amount of stylic acid content during
the development process of
bio-therapeutics is often highly desired
just attach what we covered earlier the
two most commonly observed forms of
stoic acid on biotherapeutics
are are n-acetyl neuraminic acid often
abbreviated as
nana or mu5 ac
shown here on top as the purple diamond
and m glycol neurominic acid abbreviated
ngna or new 5gc shown here
on the bottom as a lighter colored
diamond
nera or nana is produced in humans while
ng a is observed in long-term expression
systems
now let's talk about total salic acid
quantitation
the azure advanced prototype acid
quantitation kit offers a high
sensitivity high throughput approach
for total salicylic acid quantitation it
is a 96 well plate based assay
based on a coupled enzyme reaction that
begins by converting stolic acid
release by salidas a hydrogen peroxide
which then reacts one to one with a
fluorescent dye generating intense
fluorescence
and or absorbance signal here's a
general scheme of how
things work inside an individual well 10
molecules of glycoprotein is incubated
with solid base a for 30 minutes these
glycan
sorry release silic acid is then
converted and developed over
60 minutes to generate the one-to-one
complex of hydrogen peroxide
with the reporter diet and then the
plate is ready to be read
in the standard plate reader
since different glycoproteins can have
varying amounts of glycosylation
this can also mean varying amounts of
saturation so it's a good idea to start
with an amount of glycoprotein that
won't give a good signal
for example map there has low levels of
stylic acid
so a larger amount of proteins is
necessary while something with
a lot more solid acids such as fetus or
embryo requires less
in this set of examples the pico moles
of protein for 10 molecules of sample
is in the last column on the right this
will be useful for the subsequent
multimodal calculations
in the following examples
here is an example of the data that can
be generated using the kit
using a set of standards alongside the
actual samples
we can use the fluorescent signal from
those standards to generate a standard
curve
and use the fluorescence from the
samples to calculate the mole value of
silica acid present in the sample
we can see here that something highly
saturated such as fetus
and or embryo has a lot more stolic acid
per mole of protein compared to a
monoclonal antibody
like rituximab thera i also want to
point out the good percent cvs
that can be obtained from this workflow
as well
on this side we see operator operator
variation for several different
target glycoproteins we can see that
for most the percent cv are well below
10
for most samples showing that reliable
and consistent data
can be generated with this kit even with
different users
here we here we looked at lots of lot
variation of the nano solid acid
standard that is supplied with the kit
here we can see that the solid gas
standard that is crucial to making sure
that that reliable data can be generated
is consistently is consistent across
three different lots
of of salic acid
and here's an example of what the
standard curve can look like
when following the workflow protocol we
see good linear correlation between
fluorescence
signal and solid acid concentration with
an r squared value
nearly one
and now finally i want to finish up and
discuss briefly an analytical workflow
option for profiling different types of
stolic acid
here we see the two different types of
solid gas that we discussed earlier
nana on top with a structure to the left
and
nigna on the bottom with the structure
also with the structure to the left
both of these types of stylic acids are
similar in structure the one difference
is that nigna has an additional hydroxyl
group
and this is enough to make negan
potentially immunogenic to humans
in order to distinguish between these
two types of silica acids
one of the commonly used methods is to
release acetic acid from the glycan
and glycoprotein followed by labeling
with a fluorescent dye such as dmb
and then lca separation and detection by
fluorescence
and or mass spec
on this side we see an example of the
silac acid reference panel
this is a mixture of different types of
solid gases labeled with dmv
separated by lc followed by detection
with
both fluorescence and ms the first peak
is the in the chromatograms uh are are
the two main types of celic acid we have
been discussing the first peak peak a
being nigna
and the second peak peak b being nano
the other piece in this chromatogram are
other very versions of stylic acid
which are acetylated acetylene silic
acids
are often observed in nature on
molecules such as epo
here is an example of stylic acid
profiles from a few different
biotherapeutics as well as the nist map
these annotations were made based on
retention time comparison with the
stylic acid reference panel
as well as ms data for toxin
we see mainly in u5 ac with a small
amount of new 5 gc
below that embryo has only a new 5 ac
present
the nist map contains only new 5 gc
and the texture map contains mainly new
5 gc
with a small amount of new 5 ac i should
point out that
that the agilent now offers direct sales
of the nist map and
in 25 micro alec mod sizes either as a
single pack or a pack of four
and on this slide we have ms data for
dmb labeled stylic acids from embrol
on the left as well as the tux map on
the right
for embrol we seem the main peak being
426
m over z consistent with dmb label and
u5 ac
and cetuximab and for satexamab we see
the main peak being 442 consistent with
dmb
labeled e5 gc the mass difference
between these
two is 16 daltons consistent with new
5gc
being hydroxylated so in summary we
cover the benefits of the gliac sample
prep workflow compared to older and
traditional methods
we cover the benefits of instant pc in
terms of its fluorescence and ms
sensitivity
as well as the speed of the sample
preparation
we talked about the use of gyx with 2ab
for those that want the benefits of a
faster workflow
but have to relate new data to
historical data
we went through the benefits of using
siloated glycan standards and libraries
as well as an application of
exoglycosidases for structural analysis
of n-glycans and we also covered
a workflow for total solid gasket
quantitation available from agilent
as well as dmb labeling for
profiling of stylic acids
please feel free to reach out to us with
questions and inquiries we are
always happy to discuss collaboration
opportunities glycan sample prep
workflows
glycan standards enzymes product
demonstrations
as well as new technology ideas
and with that i'd like to thank all my
colleagues here at agilent
and open up the floor to for questions
thank you
thank you dr yan for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box to your left
okay let's get started our first
question is
how much glycoprotein can i use with the
glycex
sample prep platform for release and
glycans
um so so the manual recommendation for
that would be 40 micrograms but that can
go up and down depending on the protein
and how much sample is available
thank you for that our next question is
how much glycoprotein
can i use with the cyalic acid
quantitation and profiling methods you
described
so the recommendation on that it kind of
depends on
the protein itself and how much stylic
acid is on there so it's really kind of
protein dependent
i think in the manual we have some
recommendations around
igg monoclonal antibodies but if people
have specific questions they can
obviously reach out and we can try to
help them out
thank you our next question is are the
gly x
released n glycan prep protocols
automatable
um so the glass the glass
protocols are currently automatable on
hamilton systems we have an application
note from a few years ago that's
available
um they're currently in the works to be
automated on the
asset map bravo system that's in the
works
thank you our next question is can you
elaborate on the sample
clean up process after derivation um
that's a little bit of a question i'm
not quite clear about maybe we can
follow up offline about that
with the um with a questionnaire
of course we'll move into our next
question
how many samples can i process with the
gly x
and glycan kits
so the kits come available in both 24
and 96 count
formats so they're designed to be able
to process
at minimum 1 and up to 96
at a time
thank you for that our next question is
what is the difference between
your reagent
i lost that question our question is
what is the most common adduct scene
in ms analysis of instant pc labeled
glycans
um i've tended to see mostly m plus 2h
for most of the glycans we've looked at
for some of the larger
glycan the possibility m plus 3h
and also different addicts with sodium
and potassium as well
they're possible
awesome thank you dr anne that's just
about as much time as we have for q
a today so thank you for the audience
for your outstanding questions we hope
that you found today's presentation to
be informative
and insightful this presentation will be
made available for on-demand viewing
so don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on
today's agenda you can visit the event
presentation schedule
in the auditorium thank you again for
your
participation until next time goodbye